[Musique]
si je vous disais que les dinosaures ne
sont pas vraiment disparu qu'ils sont
toujours parmi nous vous auriez
peut-être tendance à répondre oui oui et
elvis presley n'est pas vraiment mort
les astronautes des missions apollo ont
pas vraiment marché sur la lune
et puis un coup parti la terre est pas
vraiment ronde
mais pourtant je vous le dis les
dinosaures ne sont pas vraiment disparu
des dizaines de millions d'années après
le règne de tyrannosaurus rex et ses
comparses du crétacé la rue saint-jean
tatus pullulent dans les centres urbains
mais l'obstacle onu lathus dans le
désert australien
parfois même dans certaines maisons et
on peut régulièrement voir gallus gallus
en campagne parfois même envie bon les
non usuelle de ces petits dinosaures
love go et la perruche et
poulson pas mal moins préhistoriques
mais oui selon la majorité des
paléontologues ce sont bel et bien des
dinosaures les seuls avec les autres
oiseaux à avoir survécu à l'extinction
quand on les regarde d'un peu plus près
c'est indéniable ils ont bel et bien un
petit air de famille leur sauce en creux
et rempli d'air la structure de leurs
pieds est similaire et l'orientation du
pubis des oiseaux rappelle celle des
petits dinosaures carnivores et tout
comme les oiseaux les dinosaures étaient
en vie par c'est-à-dire qu'ils pondent
des oeufs on prend pas et s'ils taux de
toutes les ressemblances anatomiques il
y en aurait plus de 125 aussi on trouve
de plus en plus de fossiles de
dinosaures à plumes
d'ailleurs même les tyrannosaures avait
probablement des plumes
je sais ça entache un tout petit peu
leur image de bête féroce et sanguinaire
mais c'est comme ça
[Musique]
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
à l'origine ces plumes là ne serait
probablement pas avant elle aurait
évolué pour fournir une meilleure
isolation aux dinosaures puis ils ont
utilisé ce nouveau manteau tout chaud
pour séduire après les collerettes et
les crêtes spectaculaire de plusieurs
espèces les plumes sont vite devenus la
tribu idéal pour les parades amoureuses
puis un peu par accident les dinosaures
ont fini par utiliser leur plume pour
conquérir issus de petits dinosaures aux
allures de rogers pourrait probablement
très vite à un moment donné ils ont fini
par décoller du sol et puis à la longue
ça finit par devenir un avantage
évolutif
et nous permettre aujourd'hui de
contempler ces rescapés du crétacé
simplement en levant les yeux vers le
ciel